Welcome to homework assignment #5.
Today I only have programming assignments. One on smoothing and one on control.
In both cases, we are trying to drive a car on a racetrack as fast as we can.
Okay? You'll see in a minute what I mean by this.
But think of the car going on an oval just like that.
So in this first exercise, you're going to go through a sequence of improvements
of the code smooth.PI.
I'm giving you a path that is very much a box path.
It starts at 0,0, cranks up the estimation all the way to 6,
then increases the y all the way to 3.
It goes down on x all the way down to 0, and then uses the y all the way down to almost 0.
If I draw this, the way this looks like--
we start at 0,0, all the way to 6,0, then we go up here to 6,3, and you go left to 0,3,
and down to 0,1.
This is a cyclic course so we're smoothing before what's for an open path.
I'd now like you to modify smoothing, so it can smooth this path over here.
So I want you to run the function smooth with path as an input--
the weight_data of 0.1 and the smoothing parameter of 0.1 and tolerance of 0.000001.
When you run it, what it should produce is a path like this, that when you plot it,
it looks a little bit like an oval.
You can look at these numbers carefully.
It ranks the corner points more into the interior.
I want to do it in a way that is cyclic, so that the last point connects smoothly
to the initial point over here.
So please modify the code just to be a cyclic smoother as opposed to before
it wasn't a cyclic smoother, and make it so each point get uprooted.
You don't keep 2 of the points fixed.